greetings from podcast Ville it's
Wednesday the 20th the [ __ ]
November a week away from gobble gobble
gobble [ __ ] it the Church of what's
happened now is brought to you by hims
listen this holiday season is upon us
and hymns is erecting the biggest Black
Friday deal of the mall you could try a
free online visit to get started with
him 40 percent of men by the age of 40
struggle with not being able to get and
maintain an erection why do guys turn to
weird solutions or do nothing at all
when they could turn to medicine and
science for hems calm is a one-stop shop
for hair loss skin care and sexual
wellness for men they have well known
generic equivalents to name-brand
prescriptions to help you combat IDI do
me a favor feast your eyes on this you
could try hymns today by starting out
with a free online physical day for hims
fo r hims coms slash church for hymns
calm slash Church prescription products
are subject to doctor approval and
require an online consultation with a
physician who will determine if a
prescription is appropriate see website
for full details and safety information
again that's for hems comm slash church
the podcast is also brought to you by my
bookie listen attention past present and
future my bookie plays nothing in life
is without risk
these days even go into the [ __ ]
grocery store you can take a bullet to
the [ __ ] eyeball but during
Thanksgiving week my book he's offering
a risk-free bet on the Bears lying game
choose a team against the spread for up
to 250 if you win you got some cash for
the holidays if you lose congratulations
to you as well
my bookie will give you your money back
this is Thanksgiving with all the
[ __ ] gravy
so do me a favor log in to my bookie dot
AG make your first deposit with promo
code Church CH you are CH and my bookie
will
you deposit dial $2 to jumpstart your
bankroll and that's on the top of the
risk-free bet
let me repeat that's a guaranteed
deposit match and a risk-free bet for
thanksgivin only that's next week a week
from tomorrow so stop waiting on the
sidelines like a [ __ ] Mook jump on
the [ __ ] gravy train it's the
holidays you make them you need to make
some door a me and it starts at my
bookie dot AG use code Church you play
you win you get [ __ ] paid take
this meal League what are you nuts or
what what's up my brother had him write
some doggy always a pleasure to see how
really it's truly the best looks the
handsomest [ __ ] everything sound like my
mind man oh my hair don't you look good
what's happening chillin man just uh
enjoying the day join the I like this
pre holiday time it feels good it feels
like everybody kind of lets their guard
down a little bit and especially in LA
where you know if the road rage is
always at at a high level I feel like
just everybody on a hole just kind of
you know levels out a little bit and
loosens up yeah a little bit yeah
loosens up for six weeks that's kind of
is that crazy and then just back to the
grind of the [ __ ] and it's like
January 16th is traffic people yelling
on the flip of a dime people get back
dude yeah go on in dude merge yeah
actually you know what you want to swap
cars for a day dude I'm traveling to
[ __ ] you know Toyota Corolla you got
a [ __ ] Hummer let's swap lives for a
cup and then I got my wife in the trunk
you can [ __ ] before I drop her off on
the 170 degrees [ __ ] trunk [ __ ] it
people used to be very generous with the
trunk [ __ ] yeah but you can just pull
[ __ ] real quick do it real quick good
high-five me while you're [ __ ] her do
it now you don't have a committee admits
your that yeah even if you do I'll pay
for the bar pay for the grains shake um
January 16th believe it's November no
nothing it's uh it was just Halloween
ten days ago like that's what it felt
like wow dude when he put it in
perspective like that yeah people were
uh what about last Christmas like I feel
like last Christmas was like two months
ago
wow wow what are you smoking where
Christmas fell two months ago I guess it
did though really this year the holidays
are the benchmarks for like how you
it truly right it's kind of
we view like you know how slow or fast
times moving do you feel like [ __ ] slows
down and goes quicker as you get older
because I've already not heard both
sides I think it's [ __ ] quickened up
one minute I was 21 jumping up and down
eating Gorilla Biscuits I was 37 and
some [ __ ] room and craig colorado
getting tomatoes thrown at me the next
minute I'm in Hollywood I'm 44 years old
yeah I got about quitting cocaine you
know the next night you're having a kid
at 50 I mean you know it happened like I
wake up in chunks like if I wake up in
chunks to like make that t-shirt I'll
buy the wake up and chunk yeah that's a
great way to put it
you know it's like these fragmented
memories there's a guy in Vegas once
it's 92 year old guy was talking to him
in a bar at the atopic Hanna and he
looks over he knows how it is probably
five six years ago he said how do you
also call 532 and check I've never been
32 he said I was actually a pool boy
here at the Tropicana 32 what a great
time he's like I should just live by the
seat of my pants
smoke pot do do drugs by math sell meth
say I remember one time 32 I met a
couple of foreign girls at the pool
brought him up to the room paid him to
scissor each other in front of me for 30
bucks they bought me lunch I was like I
think you're under estimating or over
estimating I'm sorry what I'm doing at
32 but I appreciate it
this is there's no way there's a
similarity in the way you were living
tower I'm living but he was like me he
goes my point is enjoy it he goes cuz I
remember all that [ __ ] cup watching
lesbians eat each other out next thing
you know boom I'm 96 no it's just like I
thought you were 92 he's like who knows
it sounds like you're talking to Joey
who like time travel from the future
yeah that's what he tells me to do like
see every day good where's your bridges
that have any [ __ ] oh yeah every day
but what would you do if you oh I would
do that I would pay them the scissors
yeah that's the first and foremost
before a meal or a shower yeah yeah
let's get it out of the way no it's like
you think how life is so unfair it can
be you know stupid yeah I'm not saying
that you fall into a trap I mean like
just dumb [ __ ] yeah you buy what's those
two condos that people buy in a rouble
timeshare sometimes you never go down
what everybody I was gonna go to Aruba
yeah we all make those weird things but
you look back when I look at my wife I
see four three different people like I
see a kid that was just a geek that just
wanted to be accepted and did karate oh
no way I see this kid that his mother
died and now he's doing drugs oh he's
doing criminal [ __ ] and then I see this
kid that's doing comedy on the road and
Wow - thinking about like I can't wait
to feature like thinking about I can't
wait to feed you like yeah I'm featuring
for Tribble and this guy in that [ __ ]
guy but I can't wait to be a legitimate
feature out of a club you put that up on
a pedestal it was like things are gonna
change yeah and driving rank and not
seeing anything for miles just tumble
[ __ ] isn't knowing you know that's
when I think of my life I see like four
different Joey deer oh yeah well that's
the one-man show that's how you break it
up were you a geek before karate or did
you do karate because you were like I
think I got too much you know geek vibes
I'm going out there karate Oh level me
out karate because I was a geek we've
got my I'll see that wow really got beat
up like what just I got beat up at a
park or I got hit in the head with a
lunchbox I don't like the feeling like
you know my father was dead I couldn't
speak the language and I was being
raised by a mom so when people would
talk about going for knick game with
their dads I felt left out oh I know
that feeling when you have that feeling
of being you know like that outside it
to happen and then get hit with the head
with the lunchbox and it wasn't called
bullying back then it was quoted that's
assault by the way getting hit in the
head with a lunchbox even if it's your
favorite cartoon but it was what it was
the second Central Park there ain't no
assault there's even one others happen
when you walk out a lot Central Park
most dangerous Park in the world huh
well at the time is too big to really
track all the encounters right teach you
to use even the birds you like dude I
[ __ ] because there's no part of that
part ends up in Spanish Harlem like
there's a tail into that Park that's a
Spanish Harlem
so the junkies were going there is shoot
but this is way
before like when I got hit day I would
just went there as a little kid with
kids my age yeah they wanted to take my
lunchbox and then they hit me in the
head and I felt so insecure that I
joined the rock and then the kids that
were in karate with newer geeks they
went to Bruce Lee movies then I moved to
Jersey and I joined karate and we were
geeks we went to Bruce Lee movies went
to Chinatown on Saturday and looked at
Chinese magazines oh yeah someday we're
gonna go to Hong Kong and fight the
Masters oh yeah but you know what you'd
have in that sense of community huge
looking back like those guys that were
in your worlds are kind of like you know
four or five of us yeah do drugs
we're very healthy and then why dipped
into drugs in my neighborhood had to
live two laps I lived a drug life with
my buddies from North Bergen and I lived
the karate life with my buddies from
UNICEF Jesus Christ now that was karate
if that was the plot of Karate Kid I
would have watched it at 15 I was the
karate kids didn't know no you were you
were living separate lives so some
savage I go I can't see you guys I gotta
work at my mother's ball [ __ ] you I was
going to the city with my other buddy
oh just blowing angel dust and play
three-card Monte and [ __ ] you know go
to strip club into those gates did the
drug buddies know that you had karate
skills yeah cheese disposal knew that
yeah cuz in those days you didn't have
black bags or Nike bags like after that
you rode your gear up and you rolled
your belt around the key to controlling
with the cup in the middle of town yeah
yeah sure for afterward so you go to
karate with your especially once you got
a a purple belt or a green belt oh yeah
show people of course lowing just a
white that's a proud color so you get on
a bus with a bunch of green belts and
brown belts and you know so that's
another part you know like you look at
your life and you go like Lee right now
even now a dirty one
there's the podcast I'll a leave then
there's the Emison Lee yeah on it it's
two completely people the guy in Austin
didn't smoke pot the guy on Emerson
didn't hear anti-semitic slurs the guy
at I'm just didn't ever scissor dreams
you know you know that stayed the same
consistent there it is crazy how
it's just like like for me it's
completely different people almost I
guess - a little bit but do you think
people change like like on the inside I
still feel similar but I guess it's I
act a little bit differently like how
like how similar do you think you are or
do you think you've changed three or
four times yeah I think so I think
whether you you can see it or not in the
mirror like just because your
experiences from five years ago are
completely different the people in your
life even if they are the same are there
different right so you're you're always
getting you know new perspectives and
new thoughts coming at you and that's
just gonna like continue to you know
shape and form who you are and what you
think it'd be like right like even my
you know sister has chilled out big time
in the last ten years and it's like she
that you know and that's affected me
because she was so [ __ ] crazy and off
the rails and had to go to a boarding
school and now she's like I look at her
as like a a person with like who has
self-worth and like you know and
actually a good parent now and it's and
that's seeing that happened to her has
made me probably you know subconsciously
just have even more I don't know hope or
have that bleed into this business where
you might get down in certain points but
you're like [ __ ] man there's always room
to grow and there's always you know new
new avenues to go down and I mean I
don't know I don't think you ever level
out as a person you know and that's why
I think my life will stay the same
yep you know I had beliefs and then when
I got the stand up I looked over the
beliefs in a different way if I wanted
to be funny because once you become a
stand-up you have to look at your
beliefs where you actually think is
sacred
yeah and you have to go for it a little
bit you know same way you just have to
go for a little bit even though it's
sacred to you you know whether it be the
audience appreciates a yeah you know
will there be anything you really got to
attack yourself
yes I'll attack all this [ __ ] that
you're gonna have a hard time saying you
know it's not hard to say what you want
to say sometimes on stage if you really
want to say you know last week they had
a thing about sin chick
from America and she went to Isis bill
and Blum is this guy got pregnant and
now she's trying to come back I'm Barry
my beliefs is an American has [ __ ]
that [ __ ] let her [ __ ] rot over that
she crossed borders to go suck Isis deck
against what she's coming down was that
true that's what she went there for she
ordered a plane colonize his bride eeeh
Isis bride she had a long-distance
relationship with an Isis guy went over
there [ __ ] already get some some
terrorist [ __ ] yeah got pregnant yeah
got pregnant and wanted to come back
with a terrorist baby yes oh and I have
no no and I said some things are there
and some point I'm people hit me up with
a like you know what man some people get
offended by your terms but I don't
because I know they're coming from your
heart yeah you're very anti terrorist
like I just I think that there's people
that steal and people that lie and
people that have death coming to them if
they get hit by a building nobody we
can't but I don't think it's fair that
leave his mom go to a mall on Sunday and
get shot just for being there yeah I
don't believe that I believe people have
things coming to there's a lot of bad
people out there so you know Karma's
real for sure when it isn't rich and
it'll come get you but I don't think you
should be you should be at war more
getting school supplies [ __ ] now it's
some fifteen-year-old drives ten hours
to shoot you whether it's homegrown
terrorism whatever the etiology all of
it you know I was in New York in 94 I
was in New York when they tried to bomb
the World Trade Center I was backing out
I was doing stand-up and I was passing
out packages for a phone company a guy
would give me 400 a week there just go
into a building and pass out intro
packages on sunshine communication yeah
I was you what you get and stuff like
that right and I'll never forget that it
was like atom rain was supposed to call
me at 12 never called all these people
were supposed to call me if a coke
because it was Friday so this Friday
coke dad did Friday it was coke base
what was Wednesday I'd be in the city
and you would call me oh joy do me a
favor pick up a gram on the way back or
give me 60 bucks yeah cuz I can't make
it to the city so it was coke day so
when I realized it was like three
o'clock
why hasn't nobody gotten to me
and then I said after the story somebody
goes you don't know what happened they
just tried to blow up the World Trade
Center and that's the tower that
controls all the communication
Oh to the pain huh this is when they
first tried to do it 94 I remember that
based on with the truck and they went
back and asked for the deposit and they
did something blew up right there was it
was an explosion of parties yeah but I
still remember seeing people on the
Atrix and say the looks on their faces
like how could something like this
happen you know never mind 911 never
mind
the candor Vegas thing never mind all
these things you know you're in Vegas
enjoying a country-western concert and
also you getting shot up by a [ __ ]
window for all these acts no matter what
you call them I have something against
that we went away from what we were
talking about but it's like when I got
off the coach I got all these strong
beliefs back about myself I had before I
started doing coke
these are the beliefs I believe when I
was 13 oh wow I went all the way back
yeah like it went like those beliefs
damn dude started coming up so coke is
just blocking so much clarity how so
much clarity I remember I was a man in
it wow you come up to me with that
stupid goof on your face knock it off
before we became comedians were men some
knock it the [ __ ] off and so all that
came back to me like that all I had
covered up all those emotions I think
your emotions and your beliefs stay the
same thousand your scent I agree I goof
around a lot on the [ __ ] that I have
strong beliefs against because it makes
me a better comic yes I have to yeah you
know it's like I owe you Lee's like I
don't like EMS for you to become a
better comic he's gonna eventually I
think somebody there's because that's
part of the discipline yeah
do you things you hate do me stepping
out of your comfort zone empanada your
cuz that's how you figure who you are
it's the only way to do it only way to
do it so I don't care what you want to
do what you want to do really makes no
difference
yeah what do you not want to do it you
wanted
du has gotten you to nowhere Wow so if
it's gotten you to nowhere why are we
still playing this [ __ ] charade
Wow did just do what needs to be done -
outside you I think to become a for me
to really start him with comic I had to
say [ __ ] that I didn't want to say about
the Catholic religion what are you
kidding me I love Catholicism I was
raised on that you melis said you've
never blasphemy I'm up there talking
about pedophiles smoke you know so I
want people understand like yeah a
church guy I'm a Catholic I don't ever
want to hear a [ __ ] Jesus joke but for
me to become a better comment yeah I did
say gho and I had to come to a
conclusion that the Jews killed Jesus
you know and was about yea the Last
Supper they knew what time it was you
want to buy all this religion to the
like caveman yeah takes my bread the
bread that's my body that's not the way
it was yeah Jews didn't even let you
pass the bread away they came with carbs
what can I say yeah they came the knives
I've started stabbing [ __ ] so
all those things you have - that was my
first attack it's so funny that you say
that even just getting like the the
balls to split that line and have
something that means so much to you be
able to poke fun it's like I just got
slim I just did the Dolby with Dane Cook
last Saturday and this joke about being
Jewish going to be in the NBA and I just
had this new tag right I make fun of how
my mom say never be in the NBA no Jews
near baa baa blah blah and then I tagged
it with I go Jews never be in the NBA
we're done showering in groups and then
people kind of gets it gets split with
like a lot of O's but a lot of laughter
and then I go okay guys it's a good joke
I go you don't have to like it here you
can laugh on the way home if that's more
your speed and then that gets like an
also another reaction and but I haven't
stopped doing it I've got a lot of
comics friends mind that respect Batman
it's a good tag you know it's a funny
end to that and you know shimmy and I've
been to the camps of Bar Mitzvah I'm
very I'm Jude through and through you
know but but again it's like at some
point I had that thought for that jokes
like you somehow your religion you know
yeah there's gotta be some a lot of
stuff about you know what
I first did that bit about going to a
sailor oh it's true how bad the food is
oh yeah how is my dad this is a good
joke yeah I think it would have been a
lot better joke of a Jew and without
their yelling a thousand percent [ __ ]
that fool yeah [ __ ] nanana have you guys
gone
what do you call grandma yeah yeah I
know some private party can't say this
one say that you have to say what you
havin fun bleep you gotta say [ __ ] you
and your filter finish with shoes Jew to
really break through as a Jew yeah he
has to go up there and do one of the
weirdest things ever and that's Megan
lash would show even though he had a
band it doesn't mean you don't respect
that experience and that you don't have
empathy for that you know and that's
what this woman was coming at me for on
Facebook she was like I just think you
as a Jew to make that joke and a comment
on a situation what what and then she
was you know she liked you even know
what the Holocaust I mean now she's just
questioning my you know understanding of
historical events and I'm like yeah and
you know I just put thanks for coming
out glad you enjoyed it
it wasn't worth getting into trying to
break down to earth her that you know
like you just said we have to take these
risks and you have to yeah you know find
the funny and things that shouldn't you
know that not everyone's thinking of
finding some humor in there was a little
Jewish guy Bulba I forget what his name
was
he he came into the Internet Ronnie
Leibovitz
no you came into the deli
yeah he's the valley's old I used to
hang at the dolly zone it's called the
deli zone Dolly's I love that opened up
by they they served the mean ham and egg
Sam oh yeah well his name wasn't that
ask welcome you been we were worried
about you think I don't worry about me
worry about yourself he was like oh one
day we were just talking and I was just
he was 93
don't call me like two years I was still
not doing Catholic jokes no way in no
way what I do what's even the realm of
possibility for you any right a
possibility I would not even consider do
it you'd see people doing it you were
like how did it do that
yeah that's I'm not gonna do that guys
up here [ __ ] boobies and one day two
of the old is the delis of were Jewish
and the other two were like that new
nationality Albanian oh yeah so was out
baby
tally light they always make pizzas one
of the best Italian restaurants New
Jersey told by Albanians that's a big
secret but nobody's supposed to know I'm
like yeah and I'm gonna forget he made
the statement one day this place because
this place bold it was terrible you
can't get pizza here you'd get better
pizza no mush which as far as I'm
concerned I'm a Jew attitude deli what
the best Jew jokes I've ever heard have
been from Jewish yeah man like a good
good solid you joke like that there was
this guy up in Boston around the comedy
club a club 56 and one day he had to be
like you don't like when people give you
a joke you're not but bad for it yeah
you think they're telling you like I
like a real story one days like you
Mandy I was in New York one day and
these four guys want a bench a priest a
rabbi and a [ __ ] Cardinal and he's
telling me to stone I'm like really
that's weird it's convincing delivery
you're just like wow what an odd
grouping and also he goes Jesus came by
like here's the joke and you know Jesus
one of the Cardinal says what can I do
for you my son and he's like I'd have a
sick aunt to say a prayer for it
God please he goes at the priest what
can I do for you and he goes I got
cancer in my foot he looks at the rabbi
what can I do for you no don't touch me
I'm on disability first time I heard
that joke I thought my balls are gonna
fly them my [ __ ]
because I grew up in New York and I mean
Jews on disability don't touch me [ __ ]
they all tell you don't touch that is so
funny
hi Larry yeah it's it's a common you
know and real stereotype that Jews a
little you know little paranoid little
uh not standoffish because we're very
loving and forward personable people but
there is like a man like a man we killed
it was brilliant oh yeah what he said 34
years ago today I was somewhere
complaining about something but it's so
weird how you have to to become a really
good comment you got to do it three or
four things that you don't really want
to talk like I hate talking about
abortion on stage like when I was why
just doesn't I don't need to put that
been in people's hearts now do you feel
that there's certain things like that
that should be off-limits or just for
you personally you're like I got nothing
funny in that just from that I person
yeah I think that people got bug Stan
Highness did Doug Stanhope got big 20
years ago he had a great abortion bit of
someone from there all these young
covenants
you know and they all had the same line
kicked the hand of an aborted fetus yeah
you know that many jokes ones I don't
like those yeah I think you're not going
anywhere with those but any subject
could be made to sound brilliant I hate
when people go well that's a happy
subject if it's a brilliant joke it's a
brillant he's funny right I don't give a
[ __ ] if it's a key enough really a
[ __ ] joke yeah he dropped
acknowledged yeah you know I mean so
even there's no aside from comedy look
the reason why I ask the question is
like that's sort of what I'm struggling
with is like I came here and I don't
know if it's my upbringing or what it is
but like I'm too naive I still buy still
trust people I go let's go do this and
all right like the whole LA stuff like I
still I feel like I need to get over and
and and grow up a little bit but I don't
I don't know if I'm gonna be 50 years
old still like oh
everybody and everyone like it's just
even outside a commie like it even even
though you can change a little bit I'm
like I feel like I'm still that
eight-year-old kid inside who goes to
Hebrew school and I'll get like likes to
eat snacks and watch TV it's I don't
know I don't know if you if that like
what's deep inside of you ever changes
like that's what I'm worried about
no mature you look at things differently
you look at your mistakes differently
yeah you'll be a different person in 10
years I hope you know I didn't like
broccoli when I was 8 I still don't like
I didn't like cauliflower when I was 8 I
still don't like cauliflower you put a
beat on my dish and that red juice
touches my you're gonna be on disability
right yeah you know this I had an ogre
tson so freshman I'd never had yogurt
until freshman year of college cuz I was
so baked and the campus store was closed
my buddy went to his dorm room and he's
like I got some yogurt so I do to
anything I'm [ __ ] starving I started
down on this and he's just like dude
you're eating that like you've never had
yogurt before and I was like I haven't
any [ __ ] he was like are you kidding
me
so then he opens his second fridge
there's like 30 flavors I go you gotta
be fun imagining discovering imagine
discovering yogurt for the first time
and seeing that there's [ __ ] 90
flavors but I mean you know there's just
there's a lot of things that that that
to me was so crazy that it was such an
eye-opening moment too cuz I was like
man if I haven't had yogurt until I'm 19
like what am I gonna experience or
discover like in two years from now you
know I'm saying it was and again I had
to put myself in a position that was
like leaving home to go to school and
like smoking pot for the first time and
then you know hanging out with kids in
the theater school that I didn't
necessarily have a lot in common with
but weed pot brought us together we had
some cool conversations that brought us
all back to somebody's dorm and then
we're hanging out listen to music
whatever there's some girls on that
floor that somebody's trying to [ __ ] and
then then all sudden there's a look in
yogurt smorgasbord and just you know I
don't the point is but I didn't new
experiences sushi tongs dirty
there we go that's not talking about 32
32 goddamn I lived in New York Joe
goddamn the Seattle is that an active
choice you've been around it right
been around it I saw desperately seeking
Susan and the cab driver Tony long ago
had a great wine I tried sushi once
wasn't that good - I brought it home and
cooked it the dumbest lie in the world
yeah I just always remember that I'm
like I don't want to eat raw fish yeah
and then some girl bought a California
roll one night wolf and I tasted the
basic California wrong I was like [ __ ]
the same and then tried a couple things
some things I hated and some things I
found well when the rest is [ __ ]
history I'd never get sushi on an
airplane would you yeah that seems like
a gamble of all time when I hear people
being like you know he's got terrible
[ __ ] California rolls Delta Airlines
I'm like the [ __ ] are you even rolling
the dice you know I don't even like
thinking sushi to go it doesn't like
this at all it doesn't hold up something
happens on that car ride something in
the six minutes to douchey so instead of
[ __ ] with it just eat it there keep
it at the home base man I use I'm not
gonna lie the again when things are
rough I pick up a spicy roll from romps
but it had to be at 9:30 in the morning
yeah well they just got sodas decanted
right you watch her like a hawk I go in
there watch that [ __ ] like oh it's
actually rock and roll routes oh yeah
butcher Rock Road route yeah yeah you
know the butcher I've used this is music
wow that's exciting there's a black
butcher that was big a rock and roll
routes awesome and I used to get him to
cook fish for me like I'd pick a fish
and he deep-fried in the back and I just
taken with the gold bag
[ __ ] incredible a little bucket so
we're homies at the local deli guy oh
we've got to be that's the dream of you
gotta be you got to make relationships
with your local vendors you know if
you're a fat [ __ ] you should know the
owner of every restaurant you frequent
you should get the norm should you take
a peek in the kitchen
I tell you all I always do yeah peek in
the kitchen let me see what the kitchen
looks like make sure the people aren't
picking their noses I don't want to evil
s I know somebody at that joint already
half my relationship with them you know
it's very my loyalty for different
products is extraordinary like if I find
something that works for me there's no
reason to go anywhere oh yeah but it's
better don't take your wife
they give mother don't take me I found I
found you don't be
would you ever start a restaurant our
own one or invest in one it would have
to be the ideal location I know exactly
what I want a restaurant oh yeah I know
exactly what I want and what I could
cover the spread for the days of carpet
joints are done you're just gonna you
can't keep up with the Joneses it's it's
too much yeah to keep alive a restaurant
a daytime it's too compelling yeah and
you know food Salmonella and all that
risk I would like a bar that served the
late night menu yeah okay if I had if I
move to Louisville reno/tahoe or
something like that I would consider a
bar ten seater call intimate couple
tables I don't want it to be you know
Brad Pitt's house I wanted to look like
you get if you fall and slip on the
floor that can be a train going through
your blood system from the floor you
want to hear people be like was that
come repute but I said the kitchen to be
spotless
yeah no mice no rats gotta be and I want
a place where people who's going 11:30
and get it opens cheese steak sandwich
in a beer on the way damn do something
that does not even exist in Los Angeles
you know I want the I like Artie
Morton's I'm one to go of my wife I'm
like hi this place closes at 10 o'clock
if this place closed at 12:30 I know I'd
be in here with Lee once a week get an
open steak sandwich yeah watch the TMT
MBA report oh yeah all you need
something easy on the two of you there's
nothing to eat around here there's
nothing like closing at 10 and a sit-in
one of the biggest cities on the planet
rise to me and a day when you go to New
York where you can make reservations at
a restaurant 1:30 I know what the [ __ ]
yeah I know man what's a [ __ ] treat
and it's how it should be everywhere
cuz there's people that you know I don't
even in a small Midwest you know I'm
going to Omaha in a couple weeks and I
know they're big on food and it's like
but that's not a place it's gonna keep
things open till 4:00 in the morning
because they just I
no maybe they assumed that no one's
gonna want to be up that late but on my
restaurant by the hotel oh yeah up the
corner have you been to Omaha before
yeah but not this is my first mother
funny bomb okay what that whole town I'm
not gonna say a name I'll get calling
her from that like 50 yard hit it up dog
they got a nice fillet oh that lays on
Friday okie what with a crab cake on top
you literally just named three of my
favorite foods no no fried yogi I've
never even known Yogi's old eyes got
khatma I had to go all the way to Omaha
Nebraska to find out that you could fry
gnocchi so they fried in your key they
put the stern line on top so big it's
gravy if they're juicing the steak goes
into the fried gnocchi then they put a
crab cake on top of that oh by the way I
just felt like I was at the restaurant
you were the waiter describing what it's
about
stop I wasn't there both days if you
were the person describing that
potential meal to me I'd be like dude
let's let's put aside eating it can I go
in the back and [ __ ] that plate I love
traveling that every night somebody is
[ __ ] going to an off collection guy
hit me up the other day and I feel
really bad like I felt really bad
because I knew where his heart was
yeah but he's like man when you come to
Dallas I know where you gonna get the
best burger I'm like listen when I
travel the last if you travel when you
got a hamburger yeah you're already
doing your step
he's just a [ __ ] step okay what they
tell you about the burger like if you
travel I would actually make a date to
go for a burger
you should deserve to be smack yeah you
know like it when I go to travel I wanna
get something from the town yes I want
to go when I go - how about what do you
think I go to Albuquerque for me
canonical Albuquerque not too many of
them I do I got on there for Winkeljohn
to see John Jones
Wow and I go down there for that [ __ ]
green chili and that Mexicans because
it's classic and class and specific to
let me access the last thing I want is a
[ __ ] hamburger not good unless it's
like you know and even then
the [ __ ] Hamburg you got gumball you
got tex-mex a [ __ ] burger you know I
had a burger in New Jersey and it was 27
miles outside of New York it's called
the stage staying like that if you ever
do New Brunswick yeah Vinny I've done it
yeah tell Vinny you want to go to the
stage the stage have to send over a
burger from the state
I love that it's 27 miles outside of New
York but it was still voted the number
one hamburger in New York City holy [ __ ]
two years in the world in New York
there's got jealous and they battle it
out but we went in there for dinner the
first thing yeah and the second the guys
are nobody's getting a burger boy not
really because I got all of you guys
know isn't New York City what yeah well
then the next thing has Dean have you
seen Dean deep down yeah oh he's [ __ ]
got the backs and the fries they wanna
send you over burger on behalf I said
send them and I've made plans there's a
Weight Watchers yeah you know me I try
killing it okay said I'm gonna make a
deal myself you know I don't know how
many calories you burn points you burn
when you're on stage and now I do know
that we're getting in a marriage after
two hours of comedy I'm [ __ ] starving
yeah I could eat a [ __ ] bull that's
why I bring protein bars in me for the
whole time good move
protein bars protein shakes you know
sometimes I'll break for a lot all it
takes a long long order with leather
love the paid the [ __ ] the hospital
clerk never tired of doing it if she was
dying she couldn't have a kid so they
wanted this kid you know that's my story
it's good yeah they patient won an Emmy
they paid the [ __ ] the hotel nurse
yeah - [ __ ] the daughter that she was in
the coma of McCarrick so my god she was
a life support system so they painted a
[ __ ] - it didn't have a grandchild who
writes that you think that was based
from a true story
Tara Tara 25 years of Law & Order is
based on stories in the paper they tell
you at the end there that's why they
make sure that the names and that
changes things all factually accurate
huh they take the story from the paper
the New York had minds
some crack mother puts a baby in the
microwave oven does just take that story
to say shoot but raise the hot pocket
yeah but to put a hot pocket in there
put twigs in there so she'd get the
flavor from the air you know I don't
[ __ ] yeah I did but uh sometimes I
take like a bag of the Reno's up now he
that like three or four chips pop thrown
away good edge to pop you up for a
minute but it's a flavor it's [ __ ]
star like I love Tuesdays at the store
because I get that God right over to
Joe's on Hollywood Boulevard
I put the hazards on and they're flying
and I get those Mexicans a 20-hour bum I
go get me two slices of the box drop you
know like your 20th price is covered
like have you know Isis two blocks away
how thick how fast that's how charges me
he gives me a lemon ice tea die if I
jump in the car and I'm still ready to
go yeah 16 points in a Thursday you do
hi oh I'm basic I'll see you fired up
tonight yeah especially with this
[ __ ] bum leg yeah I believe my wife's
cooking my wife's a great cook but the
same cookies at four or five oh man and
I and I can't eat breakfast or more when
I haven't had breakfast in a week cuz
when you take pills you know you yogurt
comes bhutya gotcha
if not you [ __ ] those blocks of blood on
them [ __ ] yeah once they give you muscle
relaxers and vicodin and cause you up
right so you got to eat the water you
hate this [ __ ] yogurt Jamie Lee Curtis
stuff right yeah yeah a lot of yogurt
well who would have thunk that Jamie Lee
Curtis would be the face of [ __ ] yogurt
you know Activa right is that what you
down on no she was a spokesman she gets
like regular vanilla yoga okay it's a
regular yogurt it's not the stuff with
the fiber
I don't like greet [ __ ] oh yeah i SH
it's Nana steer the [ __ ] I dig
it with you on Delta Han America I'm
gonna cut that [ __ ] up and go back to
daddy
you know what I have a feeling that I
could really sense that cold buy like a
hummus company like a vine
we comics was a big Greek yogurt wasn't
big it's about three or four years ago
everybody was happy with Danny but the
food is back up yeah dude even yo fillet
was making a pretty good name for
themselves yeah if you look at today's
article people people are not eating
yogurt that much because a dietary thing
is a change I love yogurt yeah when I go
to eat I see our boy mark Sarah towel
yeah yeah yeah oh yeah when I go to eat
I always get the bacon egg just one
piece of toast and I get the yogurt ball
it's [ __ ] delicious that's awesome me
and my wife split it just for probiotics
yeah I'd split just to clean your
[ __ ] yeah yeah you gotta take case so
when you're an old [ __ ] bat like what
do you guys do a commercial like that
like hi I'm Joey Diaz and I'm here for I
don't know [ __ ] yogurt or anal pads or
something like a commercial like that
depends on where I am in my life if I
need the product but also you know I
don't it's you know if anal pads is
truly coming with like you know like
men's tampons like eight figures I mean
men's tampons is that a real thing no
I'm just trying to think of an
embarrassing you turn to ask if I would
take 50 mil to do a man plays it yeah
yeah I would do that's a good invention
for you it's like Benoit boys you put
them in your ass yeah then you come back
that night and pull them out while you
read the balloon go isn't it for after
that but you're leaking like no no Brian
goes to work and you leave a little fuse
out you throw abandon ship on the pans
will eat that money if you put a
two-finger Louisiana [ __ ] eat that look
like the debt oh then she's off for the
puffins you just put that chain of shoot
that poison arrow through my heart you
just flip it up and blood boys fall out
Yatta falls either man you're eating
that [ __ ] muffler it's tremendous
you could transpose that entire
paragraph into some song lyrics the
church was that or now is sponsored by
policy Jeanne she like Joey what's
policy genius listen tis the season open
enrollment is upon you cover your butt
for 2020 now today because even if you
get insurance through your job you might
not be fully covered there's always a by
the way most people need ten times more
coverage than what they get through
their job but getting life insurance
doesn't need to be difficult or
expensive
that's what policy genius comes in it's
the same easy way to shop and compare
prices for insurance online just go to
policy genius.com and in minutes you
compare quotes from top insurers so you
can get the right amount of coverage at
the best and lowest possible price and
policy genius doesn't just make life
insurance easy they can also help you
find the right home with insurance auto
insurance and disability insurance and
once you apply they handle all the
paperwork
listen buying insurance is a painting it
really is especially a disability
insurance life insurance car insurance
this is the way to go head-to policy
genius.com
today policy genius.com
today get quotes and apply in minutes
you could do the whole thing on your
phone right now
policy genius the easiest way to buy
life insurance getting a policy genius
calm and tell them uncle Joey said [ __ ]
that's policy genius.com
anyway back to the show so as you were
saying a couple weeks ago you and I were
at the store oh yeah it was a Sunday
night yeah and I don't know who were in
the main room yeah and I walk in and no
birds up there especially this came out
like on the Tuesday before yeah he
uproarious applause when he had level
yeah and I walk in and I go I didn't
even say nothing I just walked in and
walked back there you were back there
yeah I think the part that was back
there yeah what's the thing
Doug Benson look by the Apple the
Serritella was there I think so it's a
mobile yeah I'm looking at you doing
do you want me to follow bill and you
don't know I'm supposed to be up next
I'll follow him like were you sure do
you want to follow him and you go yeah
following building you kind of turn you
back and and part of me was disappointed
because I wanted a farmer girl you see
Who I am
yeah but the other part of me was so
[ __ ] impressed with you you know I'm
at the store for 23 years and when I
hear the [ __ ] [ __ ] that goes out down
there I doesn't even go through my ear
there was a point where I used to
torture people for being picky and
selective what kind of massage their
spots yeah besides this spot and who
they're gonna follow and who they're not
kind of file yeah and I gave them the
[ __ ] but then after a while I stopped
because I go you're gonna learn the hard
way you're gonna learn when you least
expect it you come down here you don't
follow nobody well one day a PA zhilie
want to see CBS for a showcase and you
know anything guess you're gonna have to
follow a [ __ ] like Bill Byrne
you're gonna go [ __ ] I should have
followed him at the store on those
nights after the following now I'm not
ready for this and it's so weird how
I've always loved you I think you're a
sweetheart
yeah I cheer for you when I see you on
different TV show appreciation offer was
the one about the music I saw you on
what a nice sweater and your hair was
done to the side is that ballers maybe
now yeah yeah yeah yeah we won't yeah we
were like you know super white preppy
dude right giving JD Washington some
[ __ ] they always dougie and I always
knew you were a hard worker but once you
said that to me that night I knew you
were one of us I knew that you've
accepted your fate I'm an you like a
marine if you get shot
you're okay they'll give you your momma
flag yeah there's a [ __ ] yeah yeah but
it just takes a weird
I could tell you thousand story
the store people calling up and
complaining and people who just stopped
showing down it because they had a
follow a particular person that you just
failed you fail in your own without your
giving up if you're doing that gave up
before you even [ __ ] started
[ __ ] I never understood what the
mentality was behind that yeah that was
a that was crazy and I I love you for
even acknowledging that because it's
like you know I'll be honest I'm back
there and it's like you know bursts rip
in the room and and you know I followed
you a bunch in the o.r which to be
honest like that's one of those spots
- I've never viewed massaging spots is
even an option and I think I saw people
doing it early on and I was so turned
off by it I thought oh man I was like oh
and I I was like why would you want to
you can I go before you I and I'd see
people do that and then still be at the
bar don't be a performer like I got an
early flight and they're hanging out -
drew colors and you like do I smack this
guy yeah the other guy just go hey he's
getting it he'll get his okay oh saying
you know what I know two or three guys I
hate to see them do that a lot bar shows
huh and today they're dying stand-up is
one of the most just professions where
it's like man the ball don't lie you
know I'm saying if you kind of if you
start trying to you know mix and
maneuver and just like adjust things the
way that if you're worrying about things
other than then ripping it on stage and
doing doing your job and trying to get
the most out of that for you if your
heads in other spaces at least that's
for me what I figured out if I was like
if I'm going to be concerned with when
I'm all up in the lineup then I've
already lost for the night as far as
whatever I might do on stage because
that's I've already kind of put these
blocks and barriers up of like oh I can
only do well if I'm there or I I can't
do the things I want to do because of
this and that which is so [ __ ] insane
to even actively do that to yourself
and so being at the main room also it's
like the store has become this you know
real especially now you know when I was
working the phones there
around 2013 I think and 2010 actually
and you know it was it's it's obviously
a different energy now it's a different
and and so you wanna you want to be a
part of that even morning you want to be
in the thick of it and being in the main
room and was packed like that and and
the idea being sandwiched in between you
and burr was like you know just
something I was like an outer-body
experience for a moment cuz like you
know the lineups you some you know I'll
do the 9 p.m. a lot in the o.r and then
or 11:15 11:30 and the main room
sometimes it just shakes up how it
shakes up and there are times when
you're on a certain spot or and burr
somebody will come in and and even and
guess what if you had said to like I I
got to get out of here or do or I got a
spot in the or do you mind if I go next
yeah like I'm I'm so easy with that to
again because I'm not trying to go I
have no ego about it where it's like
yeah I'll go after you and then after
because I've also again heard the people
that go well I don't wanna the room will
be dead they say you know the the be
tired of laughing bird then Joey and
then I'm gonna go up like so that
doesn't even cross my mind but I love
you so if you were like dude I gotta get
out of here or my legs hurting can I do
this and then bounce over like [ __ ] yeah
dude cuz you know so those types of
case-by-case things should always be you
know you know present in your mind but
but but yeah man the challenge of it of
like following that and then bringing
you up and dude it made me want to like
you know you you want to always great I
was watching out there I may do that you
were confident yeah like rattled cuz
that's what most American were most
humans what am i blaming this on
Americans for yeah we lose in our mind
before we get down and for years I lost
in my mind before I get yeah I could
tell you guys thousand we could sit here
till tomorrow and how many things I
didn't do because of my fear honest and
damn for real yeah I don't know what
comedy contest one time before any of us
started I'm the old man in the room the
big contest was HBO came to the town
okay and let's say we lived in Boston
and you lived in Milwaukee
HBO showcased everybody then they
narrowed it down to three yeah came back
I'm Hannah
yeah yeah and then if you were really
lucky they narrowed down to regionals
and then you went to Nationals so the
big ones are Johnny Walker I don't know
if you know this if you go into old
archives
Johnny Walker booth was huge into comedy
yeah in the eighties early nineties if
you won Johnny Walker
it was Johnny Walker HBO and San
Francisco Comedy Competition I know
about that one so you had to do
something in those three to make a name
huh to make a name yeah I get the ball
going Johnny Walker was like guaranteed
20 weeks from The Improv goddamn you
know $50,000 cash and you got to do a
spot in front of midsi on a Sunday that
I'll take his that was that was clean I
like that was but I tell me those
contests I went to and just looked
around and I got intimidated by t-shirts
my god I have like Minneapolis County's
own yeah yeah yeah there was a guy the
head of NBC sure and I'm like [ __ ] I
just ran no way an NBC jacket I just
left because I thought I didn't have a
chance
that's so crazy so but I'm not the only
person who's done this
yeah I'm known I know from experience of
living in LA people who have just not
come back to the store because it wasn't
you know listen nothing The Laugh
Factory isn't everybody The Improv on
Melrose isn't for everybody and the
comedies doesn't for everybody and I
like all three me too but I've had
people come up to me and go dog I can't
step foot in the store why it's too dark
that's true there's now that's creating
excuses for themselves because now you
don't think in my mind there's a lot of
clubs I don't like now if they're paying
the Vig I like you want to pay the
freight yeah they're just clubs that you
just don't like some about it of course
there's gotta be three clubs right now
in your arsenal I don't even know comedy
for 13 years 13 years and there's three
clubs
that from the minute you walk in you
feel creepy and every time you walk in
the year this is my last time in this
mother tell you hey cor you would have
bigger off or I don't wanna go I wanna
go to penguins I hope England's ain't
gonna pay ya you know there's so many
[ __ ] places that you don't like and I
get that I you know I think that since
I've been at the store for the last 16
months I've changed completely as a
comic because I was shopping around town
too much and I was getting whatever just
disenchanted comedy clubs I feel now
that for me to improve and grow I just
gotta go to college yeah there's no
better place than me following ahead
Emre one night you know [ __ ] brat
ain't no party to [ __ ] now yet did
follow either to the spot me where's no
[ __ ] party Evan Rogen is no party run
whites no party
you don't forget Chris D'Elia yeah if he
gets um jumping up and down along 15
minutes ahead of you
yeah you know if there's a 70 net 70%
average of hot chicks in the audience
there's the lid goes up you might as
well [ __ ] you shoot yourself like that
back cuz you wouldn't get no yeah you
know you gotta make time for them to put
their pants oh yeah I get nowhere so
what you do is you go up there you watch
them do not go up there like it took me
a year to learn how to follow heavy acts
like if you go up what you do what was
your process you got process at first
with the go up there and focused too
much I'm Lisa at let's keep it going
Felice and he did a great job he's a
real [ __ ] pro yeah okay here we are
and I'm not a pro [ __ ] lease I at you
walk in there say keep it awfully and
you fly into Leigh's energy so those
last three or four jokes Lea said while
you're sitting in the back of Missy's
chair you're picking up his word yeah is
whatever cuz you're gonna go up there
and flip right into
energy so when he walks on stage he's
gonna leave that costume and you're
gonna walk into that time you ever seen
like a play on how yeah yeah yeah they
walk walk there's five people holding
something and they just zip you up it's
like I mean in the Indianapolis 500
Pitts oh yeah yeah you up it's the same
thing you've got 20 seconds to get into
sleaze costume do his tenacity don't put
him down don't go let's keep it going
for chubby [ __ ] huh they're just
lost they love them why would you want
to do that dude why I've seen it a
thousand times
nuts let's keep it going for the
Mexicans they love that yeah wouldn't
keep it going
if the suck is dick but celebrate from
it you better and I used to celebrate
them wait let's keep it going football
moon yeah yeah you know Shawn Brian no
I'm former doctor month I'm giving them
their resume oh yeah yeah put myself
down another like who's this guy yeah
forget fanning out over it not being
disrespectfully I'm just saying you saw
me kill [ __ ] he's done tonight he's on
his way up lore okay I uh I honestly
think that's the only way to do it
that's how it is to ride the wave you
know that's exactly what I thought that
night Dubourg gave me a pretty nice
intro cuz I even said he goes it was
what do you owe me to say about you and
I go and I never even thought you know
burr was and you know we've been homies
for a few years now so so I was like huh
and I started to kind of think and I
paused and they just cuz you know right
now [ __ ] it
at first I go I go whatever you want and
then he goes really and I go actually no
it's not a [ __ ] it I got it whatever it
whatever I want he goes I got it and I
my god great now what is he gonna [ __ ]
do but he's just such a sweetheart such
a pro gives me a nice intro I was on a
show with a mutual friend of ours from
New Kids on the Block schedule MacIntyre
and he loved that show so he gave me a
glowing thing about it's like a [ __ ]
love this show you saw my buddy Joey Mac
one of the new kids [ __ ] nice great
[ __ ] got a podcast with the little
fella and then he just comes you know
let's give it up gives me you know I'm
going out there with a true opportunity
to win you know I'm saying and and again
I stepped out and he [ __ ] murdered
and I know you're coming up behind me
dude so it's like in my head I'm like I
got excited for the crowd I was like
dude if I just ride this wave
I always got energy so I know I'm always
just gonna take it up a notch and then
so it was a I got excited the idea of
get going you know burn and I ride that
wave into you and then you just [ __ ]
blow the roof off dude
and that's what happened but but having
any thought different then you know a
you know and it's like and I didn't
[ __ ] overly praise burr you know just
like okay putting gotta say man bad moly
[ __ ] said something else and then I got
riding right into them what's up you
yeah you just switch the channel there's
off the stage yeah keep them there like
a memorial you know we're thinking about
it where is he what looking for him what
side did he walk out of is it maybe I
can go say I don't know man I would go
up giving praise you know Bert said
something really fun bill said yeah
really fun yeah what the [ __ ] Mike
lowing but we're not rehashing his [ __ ]
what are you reaction Lord man so it's
just so much I called Rogan the next day
I saw something [ __ ] crazy last night
[ __ ] I went up to Adam ray asked him
if I could follow breweries like no I'm
next and he's like he's the real deal
like right now joe said that yeah
because we live for that show that's
what yeah being a comic that's what
being a human being yeah it is
eliminating
all the fear from your life to get the
most potential from your life yeah the
more fear you hide you know and I had
listened and don't don't know Joey just
said look you know I got for your
[ __ ] Hindu food so you'll feel you've
really [ __ ] sandals yeah yeah and I'm
like Thai food you know but those
insecurities are not teaching me
something like I really don't want to
travel abroad like I'm just scared
hmm like I know if I'm scared I'm gonna
do it like I should I get my visa I know
I'm gonna learn the fountain of them for
me yeah by going abroad
yeah you know and that's what was scared
of some time that we might learn
something that something good might
happen you know I took me 14 months to
get on stage the first time yeah why do
you think cuz I was scared time all the
people a trunk of a car
I break into places I sold jewelry
stores I
[ __ ] they know better I used to
pickpocket people at supermarkets
what's people looking at the owner of
leave their purse open I just walked by
Friday when you get paid they please
tell me you made that face too when you
did oh yeah so I did all these things
but I'm scared to go up on our stage
three minutes something I've been doing
all my life except without the stage
we've been being social all our lives
well that's what's crazy about stand-up
dude that you truly I mean pickpocketing
robbed whatever but there's still so
what is it about getting up there by
yourself and and having all these people
that's why so as a select few that do it
and really end up standing out through
the test of time because a majority what
percentage of the world you think just
could not even fathom I mean do there
are people that I respect on the usual
the that aren't in the comedy world
right that have other avenues that
they've you know really you know
achieved a lot of greatness in and they
look it and they talk to me with this
like deity type it you know amazement of
like I don't know how and I'm like what
do you mean me like I'm talking like as
athletes and other people a surgeon yeah
yeah a surgeon I've had surgeons come up
them and go oh hey you gonna bone stage
every night sure you sure you put a
heart back together yeah what about when
I'm cutting you with a scissor I gotta
make sure that the wrong [ __ ] sheet
you know yeah I mean I gotta make sure
I'm using a knife not a spoon that's
funny mercy my daughter had an assembly
yesterday and that dinner we were
talking Friday and she goes you know dad
I've done it with other people on stage
yes Tom I have the same by myself I
tried to explain to her that next to
death the second biggest fear is public
speaking the survey is think about can
you even think of a time when you were
though like that where you would put
those two in the same boat where you
would go death public speaking or was it
always like what deck was there a point
where you ever were like I can't imagine
being on a stage talking in front of
people
me yeah
or was it always something like I could
do that I can do but I just don't have
any robins yeah here plug this thing his
head setting all that in 86 and he would
walk through the aisles but he just
doesn't stand up there he'll talk for a
while he wants to be a part of the
people right he walked through the yeah
no you you know you up in he'll have the
roller sheets up the roller sleeves up
rubbish or his jacket off yeah I thought
that was pretty amazing
I didn't know how he could do that I
didn't make a mental note whether I
could do that or not at the time I just
knew that that was pretty [ __ ]
amazing I always appreciated people who
could just I don't know I can't tell you
that I I wasn't or was gonna do it
catcher I didn't have an opinion for it
gotcha but I felt comfortable talking
around and then we didn't like book
report yeah you gotta go up or from the
class yeah I know the kids crying oh
yeah hope them read the [ __ ] sheet
and I said that you'd that yeah and then
the sixth grade I was expecting you to
connect so or make a [ __ ]
jaw-dropping their Foreman yeah so I
think I got over it early like The Stand
you know and then people tell you you're
funny you're funny for the onion to
stand up and you're like the first time
you have to stand up you go up there and
realize that what you've been doing all
those years isn't staying huh if you
thought it was panic I have three kids
laughing that [ __ ] kickball recess I
thought I could take that energy and the
worst is when you invite your employees
oh yeah
the people you work you want to second
the third performances and you're like I
can't wait he's so funny yeah and
they're all just sitting there waiting
to laugh when you had the comedy works
finally and there's no laughs no no and
then afterwards they like he was so good
in Ewing Oh and they're always they
always do I've seen it in like a belly
room shows where there's a guy comes
brings 40 employees and he also was so
out of his element and so overly
ambitious and they're so excited and
supportive but you're you know you get a
little blue right off the bat because he
thinks like that's what's funny so he's
up there talking about like man and you
know work stuff and it's tough working
across from somebody like Ken
like yeah care and he called around he's
like cuz all I can think about is boy
what does that [ __ ] taste like and
everyone's like whoo hey what is that
the joke like he just you know
understand like and then he he's
breaking the wall a little bit too much
because he that he thinks like oh this
is comedy cuz he's it's what he sees and
he hasn't done it enough to really you
know have a point of view he's just like
this sounds funny and oh man so worse
than the badge I think what you were
saying to about getting like you know
even you telling me that you told that
to Rogen is really cool because you know
yeah you know you want the respect in
the on some level of your peers right
and and to even get to a point to where
I could be at the store and be a regular
and be on a show like that and have an
opportunity to be in a place where I'm
between two [ __ ] beasts like that -
true true legends of the game people
that are just that people look up to
like that on a large scale like you got
a you know I even had there was no doubt
in my mind to not you know and and I can
almost feel I had to kind of gauge you I
was like is he trying to [ __ ] test me
right now or is he I was like cuz I know
what I'm gonna do my answer is but it's
also I had to take a beat once I was
walking out and you cuz you said to me
after you like I was [ __ ] I was making
sure he's like because if if you were
gonna let me go and you didn't want to
seize this moment you're like I was
gonna go tell tell the little guy to
find another tall person to do the
podcast with you know yeah but I but but
he shows me who you are yeah dude it
just you just cut through everything I
have I can't I can't respect there's a
calm and getting that respect is what
you want and I do want to say this too
because it's like you know hearing that
about Joe you know there's certain
people to that you get in this business
where you you know that that have that
you put up on these pedestals right and
having like the store where it's a very
there's a good sense of community like
there's a the the fun and the you know
the pressure of some of these rooms and
wanting to crush and and I hear comics
all the time saying like dude I can't
even do new material in the o.r now
because it's packed and it's always you
know I'm following this I'm following
that so I think I just got a crush I
can't do my [ __ ] so there's there's
different energies changing every night
but but I was in
Oh our one night and this to my point
about appreciating that that you even
told that to Rogen because you know I
think we'd been on shows I brought him
up a few times in the main room but you
know everyone's doing their thing not
paying attention all the time to what's
happening prior to to them being onstage
and I'm in the o.r and Jeff Scott and I
every time I'm up well sometimes do a
little because I got a big musical
theater background I used to bring my
buddy Avery Pearson on the road with me
and he'd come on stage with his keyboard
and after an hour 20 of stand-up we do
about 20 30 of improvised musical crowd
works so any crowd work I've done in the
show we now do improvising songs off the
crowd and you know I've been singing my
whole life he sings to Joe it [ __ ]
blows the roof off and it's something
different and it's you know as a white
dude it's separates me a little bit to
be like oh there's another kind of skill
set that he's bringing to the table
that's not just jokes and a sea of white
dudes that are doing clubs around the
country and so so Rogen's back there
there Griffin and I you know I don't
know if he'd seen me really on stage yet
I know he heard you know whatever but
when I bring him up on stage in the main
room and and he's back there and I'm
messing around with Jeff a little bit
and it's a small crowd and it's fun or
whatever and and then I get off and I
see him in uh Eric talking in the back
and my first thought is and I seem kind
of like talking to Eric and I was like
my first thought was kind of insecure
about like hi Betty's didn't wasn't a
fan of the the musical stuff that we
were doing right it was a little
different and then it gets up and kind
of walks by me and I go to Eric I go oh
man was Joe was he like not speaking
highly of that he's like and Eric's like
what do you want me to say man that way
won't me say and I was like I was I mean
he's like yeah he's like he was you know
just kind of you know taking a couple
jabs at whatever that was and not in a
you know malicious way but don't know
the way that you kind of you know do
with your buddies and again we chummy
enough at that point so I don't really
take it for too much stop doing it but
there was a piece of me too that was
like and it was a real good learning
moment cuz it was like it got like you
know it ate at me for a minute cuz i was
like i mean here's this guy that like
and I am looking to be best friends with
we're but you get to a point when you're
around in the store or any club so much
where you get to be on a peer level with
someone that you want to like have that
evolve and grow and you want to hope
there's another instance where I'll be
at a bar and and we'll have a chat
that'll go
thirty forty minutes and we'll learn
more about each other and and you just
you know get to pick somebody's brain
about comedy or whatever and and in that
moment I was like oh man is that like I
start getting real insecure about is
does he now think I'm that comic because
I know I was like he hasn't seen me on
stage
now maybe thinks I'm just some guy that
[ __ ] around does musical [ __ ] in the
o.r in front of 50 people so anyway to
circle that all back around the fact
that you told that to Joe and he you
know I was pumped about it that what
that was if that means something to me
man so I probably find out somebody says
something about me they won't follow me
I'll tell Joe and me and him laugh our
asses well yeah and we figure out a
torture for this person over a sandwich
I'm certain nights there's a dude at the
store that won't come down on Tuesdays
no more why not because I'm down there
and when I'm down there he gets like if
I have a 10:30 and he has the clock but
I'm he's down there at 8:15 because he's
waiting for me to miss that by one
minute and he actually complained about
misses but a couple dudes Shaam
complained about me and I laugh at them
and I feel sorry for them yeah that you
would let a fat felon get in your comedy
career like you would let me stand in
your way where I would keep following me
and figure out how to follow me and I
know it's like that night if I were to
follow old burn I would hate a bag of
dick I would have gone home over that
analyzed it
Nestle why I followed why I blue you
know sucked a dick after bill birth was
he that powerful nobody's that powerful
it just wasn't that I wasn't that
prepared so that's how you learn to
follow people that's why I always really
liked the store yeah because it teaches
you how to follow on array of people but
if mitzi sure found out through the
grapevine oh yeah that Adam Ray had a
hard time following Joey and he's
vocalized in a few times it got back the
huh
you're dead oh yeah oh she would make
you drive to La Jolla and follow me
after I had mine like just for principle
are you [ __ ] kidding me
god I love that
scored out of there after Daniel like I
don't want to drive down then the
following like it's an exaggeration yeah
yeah but what I'm saying is that that's
what she did to help you on I will up to
her like the first ring I might do me a
favor I want my career that's last T I
want to keep doing spots don't put me in
the mainland no more and she's like why
that I go that was the worst experience
of my life
big mistake she put me in the main room
every Saturday at 1:45 that's the spot
day oh yeah - three whole hours spot
yeah when you broke yeah oh I was let me
tell you some when you get off the stage
you're like I could've sucked three
dicks
how do you know my eyes [ __ ] it would
have been better than doing that spot
because I just died like quarter to spot
you're going to die yeah especially if
we give the final Holtzman especially
this for people like Colin he had it so
all these things when you go home after
those situations you tell yourself this
isn't Morgan yeah I'm not gonna start
rollerskating again in the skateboarding
yeah
but little do you know that those
situations are my building you're very
strong yep and they may not be every
night you get every night when you go on
state listen whether you're again
whether your apartment electrician or
carpenter every time you go to work you
get something from my crosses comics we
either get something ego boosting a new
joke there's always something there's
always a result to a set always even if
you're not purposefully trying to like
you're doing a new bit to get something
out of it well you grow you grab this
from that rep lights on the nights that
you don't think you're gonna grow when
you grow might see you're like [ __ ] I
should can't no yeah and then you go
down and you have to follow somebody and
the joke you were gonna write you
changed it before you one up and at work
huh you know this yet
every little [ __ ] things you could
take out of a set it's not just when
they lose it's not like me entering a
swim race where I take for a second or
third and I lose with calmly you might
lose by not having a great set yeah but
you learn when you're another great
example that the main room that was
where I showcased the one time for Mitzi
right and all her only feedback by the
way was why do you wear a hat cuz I the
backwards hat on I was like what about
the material issues like I decided a hat
and I was like [ __ ] but it was such a
like cutthroat thing to say and I was on
this bring her show right and the back
then you know you do three minutes for
your showcase this was over 2011 and and
she was still coming around but you know
less and less but she was there in the
main room watching with Tommy and and
the runner of the bring her show I was
supposed to go it suppose to be a host
then one of the bringers and then kamek
kamek kamek that was gonna showcase and
instead this guy who was running to
bring her show said I had good energy
and he goes yours gonna do a you're
gonna cold open I'm gonna put you up top
for your thing and I was like I started
getting my head and we're talking about
massaging spots I was like dude this is
not setting up to win it all there's my
showcase like I know I'm supposed to be
later on three minutes up top where the
drinks are coming in and he's and he
made this whole point though of he's
like hey if you're ready you're ready
and you can go out cold with three
minutes and part of me was like I think
there's some truth to that but also like
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you like this is not where
the humps Ruxton be in the showcase it's
three minutes I'm going out cold like
this is from its he's back there waiting
and so I go out and drinks are coming
and you know when you're also going out
first you feel responsibility to play a
little bit of host and welcome everybody
in but I got three minutes I got no time
for chitchat and how you doing and you
guys excited for the show or whatever so
I just get up and launch into material
which nobody was really ready for and it
did not go well and I was in my head I
start making excuses right after of I
was my position it was this and that and
then Mitch EB and I quiet we you know
why I didn't like your hat and I'm just
like dude nothing about my [ __ ] jokes
or performance was critique that night
and it took me man a good probably close
to a year to like just look D
inside myself and go dude if you were
[ __ ] ready and poised and just like
how we just talked about which is
[ __ ] crazy what seven eight nine
years full circle get another main room
you know experience moment to go you
know are you gonna make excuses you're
just gonna like jump on jump on the on
the wagon and take advantage of what's
right in front of you and it's like you
know I thought for so long I was like
dude it was because I didn't get past
then because I had to go first and
that's like nah man if if you had your
[ __ ] together you would have gone out
and done your thing and Mitzi would have
been like I hope you only wear a hat you
know I wouldn't know worried about that
yeah it's funny how I think she said
things to you all sort of [ __ ] with you
looking back at it now oh for sure right
yeah to make you go home and go yeah how
should that matter but what twelve
months on that joke yeah farting in the
cop guy falling down the stairs and now
I got a [ __ ] worry about that yeah
it's uh it's such a long life is such a
great journey
you know why [ __ ] you living a half
cocked and a half scary acted and that
was bait so I was like twenty something
I was just half scared don't get me
wrong I'm kidding them people robbing
apartments and robbing cult do you have
a best kidnapping like I don't have all
the kidnaps not only I won't get okay
great you tap that after that yeah
there's a very good one but you don't
really know it's kidnapped until you do
it because kidnapped it isn't really me
calling Adam Ray's father and saying I
need 250,000 kidnappers me taking you
from one room to another without Europe
and said somebody put a gun to you know
let's go in the bedroom let's go see
that safe and how much your mother
gathered there
that's kidnap yeah that's against your
[ __ ] will Wow
but if I'm talking about like all the
criminals creepy [ __ ] I did like I
didn't have fear to do that but my
biggest fear and I had a thousand those
fears growing up I had like little
things that could have Chad
yeah not just staged little things
audition thing you might not go for yeah
I don't really want to go to the
audition will you scare them not getting
it getting it or getting it blown the
[ __ ] out oh [ __ ] yeah what are you
[ __ ] scared of both wait you only got
two things gonna happen
well enough a couple of them saying no
and then you try back again do you think
there's a time that that human beings
just on a whole like get coffee with
facing any of those fears like do you
think somebody at 20 who maybe didn't
have the experience you did you think
they're faking it if they're like I'm
ready to go I want to what do you think
some people truly are born and have this
level of confidence and just a sense of
yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna make the best
with whatever happens you know I'm
saying listen some of us are born with
more talent than other but we could all
work to get that equal yeah yeah yes
work you know obviously all three of us
had a comedy bug now we have to work in
to mold it into like a sculpture right
yeah that was the answer that was there
that was the answer no well I'm just I
was just curious if you think like
people you can if there are even at that
young age because you said it what 27 is
when your fears right is that we said
kind of went away well I was just like
it took me so long to get on stage like
nothing bothers me more when somebody
comes up to me and says hey I'm moving
to LA in 14 months what's gonna happen
in 14 months well I'm gonna got a new
job and I'm gonna pull away 800 a month
you're dead you're not gonna come out
you're not gonna put on a month because
if you know anything about life [ __ ]
happens I just ripped my [ __ ]
hamstring yeah [ __ ] happens every day
yeah yeah yeah so for you to tell her
you're gonna put a hug in a month away
and move on 14 months nothing bothers me
more that
ever since I got into comedy like I
started calmly my thing is go like if
you come to me and go Joey I'm thinking
you're starting calmly I'm the type of
[ __ ] that will drive you to your
first open mic just for you to get it oh
wow
because if I got any you tell me ten
times how you getting material ready oh
god yeah
gets ready to go up don't worry so yeah
I'm getting it ready three months man do
you know how long I had that excuse for
yeah I used that excuse I'm getting my
material ready I got a killer seven
minutes like ready it's like when you
walk into that gym and you know how much
is it to join a gym and they're like $80
like that's cheap but you see people
like sweating blood and people crawling
you like I'll be back every time you
walk down that block to get a slice the
older comes out every time is like a
what are you coming next week yeah and
then you run away again next week next
week that was me yeah next week that's
the same thing to a comic when people
hit me up I get hit up once a week a man
oh no [ __ ] I'm getting material ready
I'm thinking we going on stage I'm gonna
feed you for you in five years man y'all
gonna feature for you I don't want you
to think about it your first time on
stage you're going on stage to die
you're just going let's say to get your
feet wet now and get that rush so tough
to hear I want you to get that rush yeah
and then come back to me then we got
something to talk about well if you're
gonna come up to me and say I'm good
launch stage me nah man what kind of
material should I write it gotta get my
taste of it first yeah I start playing
it doesn't matter what material you
should write there you're not gonna
remember it the first time you go up
there 80 eyeballs looking at here and
there's nothing but lights yeah you see
the people all the way in the back but
you need to be [ __ ] blind and when
you go up on stage you can see that one
head that's popping through the back
that one guy let's try to look like this
all the way back yeah you could see all
that stuff yeah so I don't know that
ever since I got into comedy
the small tactic I saw right through it
and I never saw it again I go to a Jitsu
school
I like it where's the car let's sign up
today I want to go home and discuss with
my wife and see what plans we go this is
no one foot in one foot out [ __ ] yes
yeah and the people that start I got a
buddy that's six months and he's like
one's gonna get better what am I gonna
start getting on how do I become a
regular one
when's the bombing gonna stop I'm like
that's up to you man and that's also you
know up to just the [ __ ] comedy gods
and like the RET like there's so much
that's out of your control control what
you can control you know there's that
question when is the bombing who gets
beat up I read my husband she's like
when this descend then we come home and
just smack you again that's exactly what
comedy is the first to you it is your
domestic wife you just get domestically
on like knock the call they copy it call
JonBenet they go [ __ ] the guy who
runs the club there's nobody to call
yeah it's such a and I do it again I'm
willing to do it again yeah a thousand
when you start all over again I know
nothing I know nothing different man me
need ya like I would do it again just
that's in your blood dude I know just
get yelled at yeah like I'm going to New
York cuz I love that part of it and you
have to that's why we're here you have
ways you love that part
cuz you knew that this was gonna you
know was building to this you know I
still remember go on a comic strip and
wanting to get spots in New York and
then like lucious you had a sub tickets
door the door and you know me Dawg I'm a
great salesman oh yeah and I still
remember selling you're like doing who
but I just saw the last pass I got an
envelope with four levels and I'ma being
like on 78th Street walking to the comic
strip and going for or else why would I
give it to this [ __ ] guy for the spot
I could do a spot anywhere yeah keep
them this warlock [ __ ] into this
ticket and then with the Harlem then I
come back was your tickets high I
dropped him in last week okay you could
do and I still moving in like two spots
no way from selling tickets and maybe
like a the Mayan people like there's
nothing just remember how that tasted so
you can wash it
but have it back in your mouth again
yeah there you go that's the that's the
thing what can they find you website
that man Adam rate comedy calm is where
all my tour dates are and travel a lot
right now yeah I got Omaha funnybone
coming up and Tempe improv and DC improv
for New Year's great club yeah or some
headline there yeah
and C's phenomenal I love it I wonder
what Bobby Lee was my firt when I was we
perform well yeah it's I mean
underground I feel like you shouldn't be
there pack your intimate acoustics are
killer tempies great you're doing Tempe
improv on copper blues live that's
December 5th through the 8th and then
and then 20 20 minutes you know helium
in Portland and hyenas and Baltimore
it's all Adam rate calm be calm about
last night the podcast with Brad
hopefully we can get you on before Brad
leaves especially with dad oh my yeah my
special read the room it's out and I got
a comedy music album coming out December
13th got a cartoon with Seth Green
coming out on hulu called crossing
swords and then uh hopefully more [ __ ] I
love you I love you too man thank you so
good to see you for doing that that
night because I was getting every time
right thanks for [ __ ] you know
checking me every time I get down down
there it's always the most obscure guy
that comes true for me and lets me know
I'm not [ __ ] crazy in that night you
let me know I was just is it I guess
that doesn't do wanna follow me and when
I see him he'll always come up to me
like he tries to be cute locally you
structure this evening and I'll go you
know man I'm not sure I'm thinking about
it but I really want you to to me so I'm
taught by everything that he wouldn't
want to follow me I break his balls like
atoms break his balls the disrespectful
way yeah I tell him you should teach me
how to do coming that's what I'm missing
if I had your writing skills there would
be no stopping me but he refuses to
follow me so like tonight he will not be
down and he's never done it it's was a
night and this time was like I don't
call him for Thursday and I see he's
down there for a Thursday and I'll call
Adam
like Ken he's already oh god damn man
you know what we do it is what it is
here I got one date left I'm in Miami
for Thanksgiving but everything sold out
all I got can you father [ __ ]
the new one right not gonna show what's
that new - I've been there - made oral
yeah I'm excited not good
the only tickets that are available
right now a town hall second show
December 6 December 7 sold-out at the
Chevrolet Athena and Morton Chevallier
Peter so all I have for you guys is the
second show December 6 10:30 Town Hall
which is gonna be [ __ ] off the chain
anyway I love that [ __ ] place I'm
decided to be doing it before we get out
of here
a word from our sponsor number one
listen it's over
[ __ ] football season is halfway there
the MBA is here college basketball's
around the corner the playoffs are here
and you're still dilly-dallying listen
nothing in life is worth it without risk
these days even go into the [ __ ]
grocery store you'd get shot in the
[ __ ] head so listen during
Thanksgiving week my bookie is offering
a risk-free bet for the Bears lying game
choose a team against the spread for up
to 250 dollars if you win you get some
cash for the holidays if you lose
congratulations to you as well
my bookie will give you all your money
back
this is what gravy is all about on
Thanksgiving so when you're sitting
around after dinner hearing that the
same old story from your aunt Irene why
not make an interesting [ __ ] put a
betting quick tip quit [ __ ] waiting
around sign up today and get into this
[ __ ] game like I said you really
can't lose and you got the bowl games
coming up and the best part of it if you
join before Thanksgiving you'll still
have one last shot to take it the
advantage of their incredible sign up
offer which is login to my bookie dot AG
make your first deposit with promo code
church and my bookie will match your
deposit dollar for dollar to jumpstart
your [ __ ] bankroll and that's
on top of
risk-free bet the liens against [ __ ]
the Bears so you know what a [ __ ] you
think you're dealing with joy bananas
let me repeat this it's a guaranteed
deposit match and risk free breath for
only Thanksgiving only sorry for your
true football fan whatever the [ __ ] you
don't want to let this opportunity pass
you by listen stop waiting on the
sidelines jump on the gravy train and
get out of the action with my bookie dot
AG again grab a pen that's my bookie dot
AG use promo code Church listen my
bookie you play you win you get
[ __ ] paid the church is also
brought to you by hims listen it's
getting to the time of year you don't
want to walk around with that dick do
you know how much how much more can your
hair go back
how much more hair can you lose without
you doing anything that's why for him
tom is here a one-stop shop for hair
loss skin care and sexual wellness for
men I'm 56
I knocked my wife up at 50 but 40% of
men by the age of 40 struggle from not
being able to get and maintain an
erection why do guys turn to weird
solutions or do nothing when they could
turn instead to medicine and science
expensive pills injections where no man
wants a [ __ ] injection shanty
experience if you have with doctors and
dealing with IDI issues [ __ ] all that
check out Tim's the gift that keeps on
givin listen well-known generic
equivalents to name-brand prescriptions
to help you combat
edie hims connects you with well real
licensed doctors and fda-approved
pharmaceutical products to treat II D
prescription solutions backed by science
and made more affordable by for hims com
so see the results were other treatments
fall short stop worrying about multiple
in doctor in office doctor visits no
painful injections all the treatments
like that this is easy you answer a
couple questions about your medical
history you chat with a doctor on a
confidential review if you're approved
by the doctor the products are shipped
directly to your door listen you can't
make it easier this that's my Uncle Joe
is here
being your best means performing at your
best erectile dysfunction who needs that
you're gonna walk around like the ugly
chicken per [ __ ] prom knowing that
your [ __ ] don't work you don't need that
with these Black Friday deals they're
not gonna last long but you can do me a
favor feast you eyes on this grab a pen
start out by going to four hymns calm
slash Church and get a free online visit
free who takes care you like that
nobody uncle Joey prescriptions products
are subject to doctor approval and
require an online consultation with a
physician who will determine if a
prescription is appropriate see website
for full details and safety information
this could cost you hundreds if you want
in person to the doctor's office of
pharmacy remember that for hims com
slash Church I also want to thank policy
genius listen when going for insurance
for the policy genius.com it's that easy
and get the best quote I want to thank
policy genius I want to thank hims and I
want to thank my bookie dot AG most
importantly I want to thank you [ __ ]
savages for listening to the podcast
we'll be ready to rock and don't forget
Adam Ray dot-com Adam Wright comedy Adam
Ray comic-con yeah
don't forget Joey Diaz dotnet the
hoodies are coming don't forget tickets
for December 6th at town hall and that's
it and that's that I have a great
[ __ ] week
I'll see his Monday morning tip top
Magoo weather your [ __ ] go kick
this melee beautiful